most children enjoy school holidays more
than any other time of the year that's
true here in Kabara - a slum in the
Kenyan capital Nairobi but nine-year-old
Beatriz cannot completely share this
pleasure if she wants to play with other
kids on the edge of the slum she has to
be accompanied by her older sister Grace
in some parts of East Africa there's a
deadly superstition that albinos bring
luck prosperity and success I have to
look after her because there are people
who kidnap albino children that's why I
always stay close to her the dismembered
body parts of albinos can fetch hundreds
or even thousands of dollars on the
black market in Tanzania in particular
people believed that the flesh of
albinos has magic powers
although Beatriz is widely known here
her mother Rose make sure that the child
doesn't venture out too far people in
Kabira are used to the 9 year old but
some kids refuse to play with her it
hurts my feelings when other children
call me mad Sango the white girl what I
play with them anyway I'm her friend and
I don't like it when other children hurl
insults at her it makes me really angry
she's a good person I don't run away
from her she's my friend
Beatrice's mother and father loved their
three children equally but often albino
children are hidden away for fear of
social rejection often their mothers are
accused of having had an affair with a
white man many marriages break up as a
result Rose says she has the support of
her husband but it's difficult with
relatives in the country that our
eeeh we were treated with contempt and
hate I was depressed I was never able to
leave her with my relatives I had to
take her everywhere because no one
wanted to be alone with her I asked
myself why did God give me a child like
that so but I raised her despite the
contempt of others but it's lonely no
one comes up and talks to you at parties
you're isolated in Kenya it's almost
impossible for albinos to find a job
most people here don't know that
albinism is just a genetic condition
that affects pigmentation and that
included Beatrice's mother she found out
about the albinism Society of Kenya by
chance she hopes that they'll be able to
help her daughter therapist Lydia
magorium has been fighting for more
protection for albinos for years they're
not sure to take its course because when
when somebody does it and it goes
scot-free somebody else and somebody
else from other places they also do it
gently because this one was caught and
did nothing happened so we can continue
doing it's it sunk him yet they are
playing games with with lives and the
life is precious but the therapist also
wants to provide practical help
Beatrice's light-colored skin needs
special protection from the Sun a high
factor sunscreen should be used every
day and Lydia tells Beatrice's mother
her daughter's have has to be bigger and
that she needs tented glasses to protect
her particularly light sensitive eyes
but the therapist is also concerned that
Beatriz should develop the inner
strength to deal with discrimination I'm
telling myself I am a person I'm a child
of God and I have a life to live and
above all my God loves me
that's a view the visit will certainly
make Beatrice and her mother realized
that they are not alone in their daily
battle for recognition